the people living in israel are part and
parcel with the jewish people
and it's one body and therefore they
should feel that it's
their success i think that's something
that we're trying to achieve
[Music]
rabbi joey thank you for being on my
show 20 minute leaders it's a very
gracious of you to give me your time
thank you for inviting me of course of
course so we know each other
from a j ventures where you're also an
lp and while jay ventures has this
uh incredible mission of both investing
in
investing is part of the capitalistic
kibbutz and but while bringing together
jewish americans and israelis you're
approaching this uh
issue of the you know the difference
between the two communities
not necessarily from a financial and an
investment route but more from you know
a more cultural and community aspect
right
right in other words i think that the
jewish community has a lot to offer
the israeli community and vice versa and
i think the commonality between both
is our judaism okay so right before we
get
into that i'd love to give me a little
bit of a background about yourself where
are you from and how did you even get
to silicon valley and to ask yourself
the question how do i work with these
two communities
within the bay area okay so i'm
originally from toronto
canada um toronto is a very very strong
jewish community
also with a very large israeli
population yeah and
i grew up there in day schools i had a
very strong jewish education
i ended up getting a degree there in
university in political science
and i went afterwards to go and study to
become a rabbi
in israel i went to issue boats and i
got my ordination while i was in
jerusalem
and when i was a student on campus i was
very active
in a lot of jewish activism um both on
behalf of israel but also
all sorts of other juries it was before
the iron curtain fell
because i'm quite old and so i was busy
fighting to get the jews out of the
soviet union
and ethiopia and syria and that was sort
of my career
when i was in college i eventually
became the vice president of something
called the world union of jewish
students
and from there i decided that if i
wanted to make a real impact on the
jewish world
the best idea would be to get a very
strong jewish education
and be able to connect people to their
heritage
so i left canada i went to israel i was
there for eight and a half years
wow studied for eight and a half years i
did
wow and i ended up getting married after
the first six and a half
and my wife and i sorry after the first
two years i was there married six and a
half years
and while i was in israel i was trying
to figure out what my next step would be
and people always spoke about the bay
area as this anomaly
that there is a black hole on the jewish
map because it was under
service with respect to jewish education
there were very few day schools there
were very few kids going to day schools
there was not much around and especially
within the more traditional community
there was very very little
there were a few synagogues that were
here that were tiny
there were a couple khabad that were
here
um and so when we looked around
it looked like an amazing opportunity to
try to do something in the field of
jewish education
i ended up putting a team together in
israel and we all came as six families
we moved here in 2001 and we started
what's called the jewish
study network and the tagline is to
raise the level of jewish literacy in
the bay area
now is this for uh is this for both
israelis and american jewish people or
is this just for american jews
what's sort of the target audience for
this it's for both it's for everybody
okay wonderful and you know that alludes
to an interesting point because
it's it's a very i think this is a very
interesting conversation especially
because you know i'm i'm here living in
palo alto
and you know basically across the street
from i'm a secular jew
very israeli coming in my main
affiliation with the jcc i just had a
great conversation with zach
bodner and i told him that i love the
jcc because i get to go and listen to
israeli artists who come here
but you know i don't really go to
synagogue and
i see judaism more in the traditional
aspect of it
and i and i feel that that there
that's a part of the you know the
disparity between the american jews and
israelis
do you feel that same way or or do you
see it differently
well so there is a disparity like that
one thing that i find though
is that for a lot of israelis that come
here and
decide to try to at least investigate
judaism
it's their first foray into something
that's very very rich
and people get very excited so there are
a lot of israelis that actually
have started trying to study talmud and
trying to study the torah and really
figure out
what is it that defines judaism
um beyond the nationalism right
they're definitely familiar with which
is ironic because they're coming from
you know
israel and now they're coming to to the
gola
and all of a sudden they're becoming
more jewish that's right
that's right and they're definitely
becoming more knowledgeable about being
jewish right
that for sure is happening here um and
in a place like silicon valley
people are highly intellectual highly
curious
and very motivated so if they spend even
just a little bit of their energy in
trying to explore something jewish
it ends up being a very productive
experience for them
okay you know what is jewish studies i
i've never
went to a jewish day school i've never
studied the talmud
so now give me a very brief what is what
is jewish studies overall
okay jewish studies is a study for for
us
at the jewish study network it's
primarily a look at the classic texts
that sort of define the jewish people so
the torah is the first and it's the most
obvious
but if you go beyond the torah and the
rest of tanakh
there is a whole wealth of literature
that we have managed to produce over the
past
couple millennia dealing with all sorts
of things so the talmud
the babylonian talmud i would say is
first and foremost it's almost like a
time capsule
in which all of judaism has been
preserved by the sages a couple
thousand years ago and it deals with
everything from
law law is certainly a big part of it
jewish law in particular
but there's also a perspective on things
that people would find cultural
there are recipes there are language
conversations there's you know really
sort of the experience of what it means
to be part of this people
right the jewish people are particularly
difficult to define
because it's hard to define them as a
nation because they live for thousands
of years without a state
it's also hard to define them as a
religion because people who are not
religious are still considered to be
completely part of the jewish people
right there are people that don't
believe in god and yet they're as jewish
as somebody who does believe in god as
long as they follow other criteria
so it's almost like this anomaly of a
people
that exists on the planet that has been
through an incredible incredible history
and it has contributed to the world in
so many different ways
in terms of a sense of not just the
morality and the ethics that we say come
from the torah
but even contributing in terms of
science and the understanding of the way
the world operates
you yeah for me it's not an accident
that there are so many nobel prize
winners that happen to come from
the jewish people they're driven they're
motivated
and i think that you know there's just
when it comes to studying judaism
there is so much there when people come
to me and they say that they want to
try to understand so i usually direct
them towards a class in the torah
portion
let them at least see what it what it's
like beyond the bible stories that they
learned when they were very little
or i'll send them to something like
ethics of the father's peer care votes
where they get to understand sort of the
moral underpinnings of what it means to
be a society based around morality
and i think that all of the things that
people study they usually walk away
saying that
this informs their current life because
one thing that we believe very strongly
is that human nature
hasn't changed over thousands of years
we might have new technology
and we might look a little bit different
in terms of the way that we dress
but the way that we are intrinsically is
still the same
and so the stages in their wisdom
managed to articulate
values and principles that are as
relevant today as they were
thousands of years ago right i mean one
of the things that i that i'm
that i've discovered here especially at
stanford is that uh
not it's not only jews that stud that do
jewish studies but a lot of these things
are relevant also for
the average global citizen that the
lessons learned about the community and
culture and
and respect and they're they they they
are cross religion
and they're across borders is that
something that you also find or do you
think
contrary to that that it is mainly for
jewish people
no i would say like this i think that
there is so much of it
that should be universal and the way
that we approach it is universal
right right we believe that there's a
plan for the whole world it's not just a
plan for the jewish people
we just believe that when it comes to
certain laws that
we as the jewish people have a higher
level of responsibility
to follow particular laws in other words
we're supposed to be a little bit
distinct
and the expression of light into the
nations we're supposed to be an example
of what it
means to live a moral and ethical life
in all of our classes i think there are
people that are not
jewish that come to experience and to
learn and again
and i think that when it comes to a
sense of ethics and morality
yeah judaism has informed a lot of the
conversations
that take place both in medicine and
in law and all sorts of other arenas in
fact
you know organizations like the jewish
study network
are asked to give continuing education
credits in the field of ethics
for all sorts of professional fields
because there is value that's universal
wow so where are we headed now so i mean
one of the one of the key things that
i've observed
in israel is is definitely you know a a
very clear separation and a growing
separation unfortunately between
secular jews and religious jews i i'm
not i'm not having yet experienced this
here but
but you know coming in from your
perspective of jewish studies and you
know trying to bring together these two
tribes
here in silicon valley and looking more
globally the world where are the jewish
people headed and
and what is our role in in helping make
sure that it's headed the right way
so that's a very good question i think
that it's
true that the media likes to report on
the flash points
of conflict between the religious
community and the
secular community i think in reality
that the communities are starting to
understand each other
a little differently so for example
within the ultra
religious in israel there is a big shift
in which people are deciding to embrace
secular education
in a way that they haven't before i'm
sure you're familiar with kamatek
i i was just about to talk about moisha
friedman because i love him to bits and
he's incredible yeah yeah he is
incredible and what he's doing is
amazing
and it's just the tip of the iceberg
there are many people that are starting
to realize
that that community can't continue to
exist at the levels of poverty that
they've been living at
and that they have to embrace some sense
of
modernity when it comes to providing for
themselves
and they're doing so and the media
doesn't like to talk about it as much
it's not as exciting as the wars that go
on between the communities
but i do believe that there's a very big
shift
i think that i am a little concerned
with the relationship between israel and
the diaspora
i think that the jewish community in the
diaspora
is not as in touch with the centrality
that israel should play within judaism
right so they see it as something other
than themselves
it's the jewish homeland but they don't
necessarily feel as connected to it as
they should
and i think that it's the responsibility
of the community here to
take a look at the way that we're
educating our young people
right the ones that do get a jewish
education why are they not walking away
with a passion for israel
right i think that that is a failing
that has to be addressed
no definitely you know i'm very involved
with the birthright program
and then i also have a a giddy mark the
ceo of birthright on
on this show and and i and i did a few
of those trips myself and i and what i
find is that you know there's
the the minute you have somebody walk
into israel and see the miracle of the
holy land and the startup nation part of
it as well i think that
one of the most important things that we
can do for israel is is
talk about the is you know put aside
some of the conflicts and the politics
and the religion
just talk about the miracle of the
startup nation and what the incredible
things that it has done
and i see how eye-opening it is for
people who read the book startup nation
for the first time
and and they really understand that wow
like like a nation of now nine million
people in this heart of conflict
is able to produce such magnificent work
i think that's a major major part
and obviously the jewish studies is
important but i also think that that
that's that that combining that with the
intellect and combining that with the
successes i think that's incredible
right i think so also
the trick is trying to figure out how to
convince the american jewish community
that they should get what we call the
nares
from the startup nation what is that the
the what
yeah yeah they that they should feel
that it's
theirs also right i think that's
that's the best that's missing yes so
it's wonderful to read about the startup
nation
but if you feel that it's not you then
you're just reading about somebody
else's success
which might be inspiring but if the
jewish community can embrace the notion
that that is who they are in other words
the people living in israel are part and
parcel with the jewish people and it's
one body
and therefore they should feel that it's
their success
i think that's something that we're
trying to achieve is there a worry that
within this
centrality and pulling together is one
body
that the jewish people can start
alienating
or continue alienating others around the
world who then view the jewish people as
you know this closed group
closed-minded is that is that a worry
that we have or
do not think that's that's the case i
personally don't worry so much about
that
i think that if you look at jewish
history over the span of the thousands
of years
for most people they weren't interested
in us integrating into them
right that was never a desire per se and
in terms of today where people are
willing to allow us to integrate
i think that people have a certain
element of respect
as long as we're prepared to share
meaning if we were isolated to the point
that we developed technology that we
weren't exporting to the rest of the
world
then that would be a problem or if we
had
morality and ethics that we weren't
prepared to share with the rest of the
world
that would also be a problem but the
stronger that we become
as a people the more influence
we can have on others for the positive
and i think that that's something that
they would also embrace
okay okay now that's fascinating so
rabbi you know we just have a few
minutes left but i'd love to get to know
you know what is like your favorite
teaching the thing that you
enjoy most teaching whether that's at
stanford or through the jsn
like your number one number one class or
idea
that's a great question i love teaching
the torah and specifically there's
one section in the book of dvariam of
deuteronomy
i'd love to learn okay
and if someone were to ask me rabbi can
only come to one of your classes
one week of the year which should i come
to i would tell you to come to that
particular class
and the reason is because it contains
all the fundamentals of judaism pretty
much in one place
okay so give me you know in the one
minute thing what are
what is the fundamental according to you
with that
so i think the fundamentals are that
there is a god who created the world
and he demands a level of morality
and obedience from you know from us
that we believe that he took us out of
egypt not so that we would
be free of anything but that we would
become slaves to him
meaning that we would live our lives
with a sense of purpose
and that god created the world with a
sense of purpose and our job is to help
fulfill that mission that's some of what
you can get from that persia
and and you know but that too do you
find that that is sometimes also
could potentially alienate people who
don't who are jews but don't come from
that
background who might come in and say
like you know you know is a secular jew
i'm
hearing like wow be slave to god and and
go with the purpose of fulfilling his
mission
so how do you balance that with you know
trying to bring in israelis and
and helping them understand judaism
better and you know and
be more fond of it so i'll tell you the
truth
i think the more that people study
including secular israelis and there are
a lot of secular israelis that i study
with
the more they start to realize that
there is a lot of brilliance
and there's a lot of wisdom and they
start to
realize that there's a system that is
incredible that is incredibly
progressive it doesn't fit anyone's
preconceived notions when it comes to
all sorts of issues
um i think unfortunately judaism is a
bit of a victim of being
slapped together with other world
religions and so people are familiar
with other religions they assume the
same applies to judaism
and they don't realize that there is a
different take on all sorts of
really all sorts of issues everything
from women's issues to
financial issues to the issues of how to
structure an economy
right the fact that judaism is
capitalistic and yet
it has a way of defanging capitalism
so that it supports everybody right it's
a very intricate structure the more
people spend time studying that
the more they start to realize that
there is a lot of value in it
interesting so what i would say is i
would encourage people like yourself
to just take a little time and
investigate and i think you'll be
pleasantly surprised that it's something
that you'll find meaningful
and it'll help inform the way that you
interact with people
for many people they find that it helps
with their marriage it helps them as
parents
it helps with the way that they interact
with their community and
people feel that there is a more
meaningful purposeful life
right now and i i definitely you know
the number one thing that i take from
this is also this idea of
open-mindedness and i'm definitely
holding myself to be open-minded and
learning anything and everything that i
can
and and i think one of the one of the
issues with religion in general is that
people come with preconceived notions or
little sound bites they make
they come up with conclusions and then
they they they have their belief with
those conclusions
and and i think that this investigation
is something that we all owe to
ourselves by the way not just
necessarily through judaism i would love
to also
investigate the quran a little bit and
investigate christianity and understand
the world a little bit better
and i think actually that's one of the
key aspects of empathizing and solving a
lot of these
the conflicts that we have is being able
to understand each other better
rabbi joey right before we leave i have
to ask you the most important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
is it the most important question and
probably the most difficult question a
hundred percent
so i would say that i'm passionate yes
i would also say that i consider myself
to be
god-fearing okay what does that mean
meaning that i i try to live with a
consciousness of a higher power
a god that's aware of what it is that
i'm doing okay it helps me do the right
thing
even though sometimes i'd be tempted to
do things that are not necessarily right
okay and i think the third is i would
say that i
try to be incredibly um open and
creative
i love that rabbi joey thank you very
much to dagobah
and uh thank you stay safe and stay
healthy
okay you too bye bye bye
you